there are memos and counter memos
finger-pointing and mudslinging no signs
of an end near for the Russia
investigation in Congress but it's time
to move on says former secretary of
state condoleezza the top Democrat on
the House Intelligence and I know you've
got a really hard job and I appreciate
what you're doing for the country but I
really hope you can wrap it up the
country needs to later on the view Adam
Schiff defended the ongoing probe it's
the job of the Congress to tell the
American people would happen whether it
reaches the standard beyond reasonable
doubt or we merely find clear and
convincing evidence of collusion so it's
important I think that we sent out the
facts for the public set out the facts
about what the Russians told
Papadopoulos about what the Russians did
in setting up that meeting at Trump
Tower the secretary had more to say on
the subject on Fox News this morning I
think the American people are ready to
move on everybody wants to know what
happened but as I also said to
congressman Schiff the Intel committees
also need to focus on what the Russians
did how they did it because the first
time shame on them
the next time shame on us if they can do
it again and I think there's too little
attention to what they actually did and
how we're gonna deal with it so Kimberly
that's not that she's doing two things
one is there's a school of thought that
we just need to figure out what happened
with Russia and move on but then the
other thing is making too much out of
Russia what Russia did but not doing
enough to figure out how to stop any
further funding business from them in
2018 right well of course what you have
to do is learn from the mistakes of the
past what they can do to make it more
secure make sure that they don't have
influence try to you know cut them off
at the pass so so to speak in terms of
their interference so I get what you
saying if anybody ought to be able to
give good advice that we should heed and
listen to it's Condoleezza Rice as it
relates to this especially because she's
a Russia expert absolutely this is her I
guess area of expertise right and one of
her biggest strengths is so in terms of
national security but it's important to
get to the bottom
it to understand it to be able to combat
against it more effectively and
efficiently in the future so I think you
have to do you know both yeah one it's
interesting I understand why the House
and Senate and their committees want to
do their constitutional duty and checks
and balances but it does seem like it's
being superseded by Muller so there's at
least these three investigations going
on at the same time and really I think
that those two have become so partisan
that people are just waiting for the
molar investigation to wrap it up well I
think the house investigation is beyond
partisan I mean it is the Senate's not
so bad I don't think the center is that
bad but I think that what Condoleezza
Rice had to say is very important I
think reflects the attitudes and lots of
people who think I hear stories this day
then hear a different story the next day
and I'm not sure what to make of any of
it I think you said that at times it's
just like overwhelming like when you
have a shift memo when you have the
newness memo and who said what and who
what proves what do we have any bottom
line here the difficulty with it is that
of course when people there's a new term
out that I keep hearing people use
gaslighting that that people are
essentially being deluged with
information some of it intended to
distract and confuse them right right
and then people say oh I don't know
what's going on with this story it's
just making my head hurt and why don't
you get to the bottom of it so I think
that impulse is there but condi rice
also said she knows Robert Muller she
says she trusts robert muller and that
he was beat he will be very fair and do
a good job she didn't call for the end
of the Muller investigation now by any
means so I think we have to be very
clear about that right she is also one
of the only ones in from previous
governments that has been willing to go
actually out and say something that she
really feels most people within the
Obama administration haven't basically
said anything maybe because they're
worried about things that could come out
later yes but she does speak from a
position of authority having been at the
State Department knowing the Russians I
mean worked in a White House to know
that the I should be our I should be on
the important ball which is preventing
it from happening again we have very few
states people in this country anymore I
feel like back and in the 90s or even
before then there was these heavyweights
in the Reagan administration and from
previous administrations
that you look to that rose above
politics condi rice is one of them we
don't have a lot so it really carries a
lot of weight when she says this when
I'm pretty struck by is the fact that
Adam Schiff can get booked on the view
he can get booked on the view I should
be booked the next and did you hear the
people clap in the view audience yeah
when she says let's wrap this thing up I
was surprised by that but also not
surprised because the USA Today poll
just came out and said Russia is ranked
dead last on the issue of voters for
this country and it's no surprise
because it doesn't move the needle on
anything and it's been nine months it's
cost millions of dollars there has been
no evidence put forward of collusion or
obstruction I'm not saying there isn't
but there hasn't been any yet I believe
if there was it would have leaked by now
I want to see it wound down I don't want
to see it dropped I just wanted to see
it it comes to a rightful conclusion I
don't trust Muller I don't trust anybody
I trusted myself that's about it worried
that he stacked the deck with the people
that he's brought in what about your mom
my mom loves Muller I want to know about
Russian interference I want to know
about potential collusion but I also
want to know about potential unmasking
and also potentially fraud putting fraud
onto the Frye's of court by not
disclosing that Hillary funded the
opposition research for the warrant I
want to see it all anything else but
let's see let's see quickly okay you
know if it was you say it's been going
on for nine months that's basically two
porcupines because they have a gestation
period about a hundred twenty days no
this shows you how bored I am by the
stop it but there isn't good there's two
good points here to make number one
everybody wants this story to move on
except for the people who don't want it
to move on and it's the election losers
now remember they ruthlessly attacked
Fox News and they ruthlessly attacked
the Republicans Oh
over dwelling on Benghazi where in which
four Americans died and it was blamed on
a terror I was a terror attack blamed on
a movie everybody was mocked they had
like there were comedy shows
Colbert they were they show the fire the
flaming cars and they be making jokes
about how why are you spending so much
time
move along there nothing happened there
move along but now this is their
Benghazi right this is their thing
it's paper-thin but they're clutching on
it hard and the long the longer they
clutch it the more that they they hope
this is real the better it is for Russia
Russia is the third wheel that is trying
to break up a couple that is America
they're like the young attractive model
that moves into your condo development
right across from the bay window a
distraction that leads to destruction
are you like a peeping tom person not
anymore I couldn't be one see how
exhausting this Russia story is yes
[Laughter]
yesterday we had this whole
back-and-forth between President Trump
and the Attorney General mm-hmm and we
talked about there a little spat and how
it plays out in public then the Attorney
General has dinner with his pal while
his colleagues at Central and what does
that mean etc because he has said that
he has instructed Michael Horowitz the
general at the Justice Department to
investigate the same thing just was
talking about possible a funny business
at with the FISA Court okay so it's
already done so that today we have to
get another letter that lays out that
Nunez thinks that there could be laws
broken in the FISA thing and he sends a
letter to jeff Sessions and demands a
response I'm like what am I missing that
he responded the day before well you
know Jesse well okay I think he's
lighting a fire under Jeff Sessions he's
not happy with the fact that the IG is
investigating it I think he wants to
ramp up
a lot of people want a special counsel
because the domestic investigations and
operations guide says that you have to
put forth to a judge factual and
verified information when you're
applying for a warrant
to spy an American I don't get it the
dossier which was paid for by Hilary and
chock-full of Russian lies was neither
verified nor substantiated and Comey
himself admitted to the Senate
Intelligence Committee that it was
salacious and unverified so not I get
that
that is not honest and it is against the
law and that's what he's asking sessions
to look at for that seven you know one
of the things I couldn't stand in
Washington even from when I worked on
Capitol Hill through my time with the
Justice Department over to the White
House was how people on both sides use
letters to somebody else in order to get
press attention it is so annoying I
really like how President Trump does it
he bypasses the whole process it just
sends a tweet I don't know but see I
disagree I think it's kind of nice to
bring back the letter like handwriting
it would faint like when fans write to
me about the show I read every piece of
fan mail and I love the handwriting you
can almost guess the age because
generally older people have better
handwriting young people they can't hold
pens anymore they don't know how they
look at a pen or a pencil they get very
nervous and mail that comes from people
cutting out letters in the newspaper
sometimes I do I like it when they write
outside the envelope like they had
another thought so they mail you a
letter and they keep writing out who
jail mail well you you get a lot of jail
mail and host jail mail of a most and
they all drop pictures of me but Joe
mailed to ways yeah it's interesting
right this has been great start to the
show